- [Instructor] In this
video, we're going to try
to figure out what 0.6 or
6/10 divided by two is.
And I'll give you a little bit of a hint.
We have 6/10 plotted on the
number line right over here.
And so one way to think about it is,
if I wanted to go from
zero to 6/10 in two jumps,
how big would each of
those jumps have to be?
Pause this video and try to
figure that out on your own
before we work through it together.
All right, so as I mentioned,
one way to think about it is
how can I go from zero
to 6/10 in two jumps?
Two equal jumps, I should say.
Well, if we just eyeball
it right over here,
I could do one jump like that
and then another jump like that.
So I did one jump and then two jumps.
And so one way to think about it is
we've divided 6/10 into two jumps,
and each of those jumps are how far?
Well, each of those
jumps are one, two, 3/10.
So this is 3/10 or I could
write it like this, 3/10.
We have another one, two, 3/10.
So this is going to be equal to 3/10.
And we've thought about it in other ways.
If you have six of something
and you divide it by two,
you're going to have two groups
of three of that something.
So if you have 6/10, and you wanna
put it into two equal groups, well,
each of those groups are going to be 3/10.